[Music]
pastor mark the question is should we
prepare physically also for the sunday
law as much as spiritually
should we prepare
for the coming crisis that's going to
come when no man can buy or sell
it's a very interesting question
and one has to understand the sequence
here so the bible teaches that there's a
little time of trouble that precedes the
great time of trouble
so when the when church and state unite
and a national sunday law is enforced
there will be a time during that period
where no man could buy or sell
during that or
during that period of time
there will be opportunity for us
to grow gardens
for us to
the national sunday was the last call to
leave the major cities
we are we'll be living in remote areas
and preparing in these remote areas
for
the coming of christ
then
as everybody has an opportunity to make
their final decision from the time of
the national sunday law the mark of the
beast until the close of probation
then during that time we do make
physical preparation
but after the cause of probation when
everybody has made their final
irrevocable decision when that once that
has taken place
then
we will no longer have to prepare
because it's at that point that our
bread and water will be sure it's at
that point that the angels will feed us
um you find that in the bible very very
carefully uh isaiah 33 verse 14
and uh onward it talks about the fact
that
that our bread and water will be sure
and so we can have confidence at that
time that god's going to feed us